[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
spezielles video zum anstehenden
opferfest ich weiß meine community ist
kunterbunt und nicht jeder feier dieses
fest weil jeder aus meiner community
muslimisch geprägt ist aber das macht
nichts denn es schmeckt super super
lecker meine deutschen und
thailändischen italienischen freunde
haben alle schon mal warm uhr mit dattel
füllung von mir probiert und waren
restlos begeistert
das machen wir heute eventuell zeige ich
euch auch noch die weiteren füllungen
wir beginnen aber zuallererst gleich mit
dem grund teig und was ich euch auch
zeigen wollte dass mit diesem urformen
das hier ist jetzt hier zum beispiel die
größte ich habe aber auch noch zwei
andere in petto
das ist auch alles handarbeit und das
bieten wir auch im shop an das ist für
euch eventuell wichtig zu wissen falls
ihr das noch nicht habt ich werde euch
den link unten reinsetzen und dann könnt
ihr euch das eventuell noch zulegen
hier sind die zutaten für den grund teig
und zwar benötigen wir weichweizen krise
hier habe ich butter schön zimmer fahren
an gewürzen fenchel machen ab gewürz die
habe ich noch anis etwas muskatnuss und
trockenhefe außerdem puderzucker und
mehl orangenblüten wasser und einmal
dieses butter gibt etwas milch und
neutrales öl und jetzt zeige ich euch
die zubereitung mammut also insbesondere
moore mit datteln füllung ist total
typisch zu diesem fest also auf türkisch
ist das opferfest kurban bayrami und auf
arabisch hansa genau haben sie spricht
nämlich wunderbar aus
nein ich kann das ich kann diesen
buchstaben waren einfach nicht
aussprechen
aber egal wer hauptsache das rezept ist
hier sehr authentisch und schmeckt total
fein und möbel ich gebe jetzt
zuallererst zum gries einmal noch mehr
dazu und puderzucker und ich mache das
am liebsten so dass sich auch schon die
gewürze mit dazu gebe weil sie alle
trockenen zutaten in einem habe und dann
beginne ich butter und butter gehen mit
1 zu kneten
[Musik]
so ihr lieben ich habe jetzt die
flüssigen zutaten hinzugegeben und ihr
bekommt dann einen kompakten teig der
ist keinesfalls irgendwie fluffig oder
so er sogar ein bisschen hart aber
wichtig ist wenn ihr denn hier
zusammendrückt der bleibt dann zusammen
und so ist er genau richtig und falls
sie merkt also ein bisschen bröselig
dann führt ruhig noch etwas milch mit
dazu aber ich bin jetzt hier an der
schule fertig decke das ganze ab dann
nehmen wir uns einfach einen teller und
dann kommt das ganze in den kühlschrank
für zwei stunden mindestens ihr könnt
das ganze auch am vortag zubereiten
je nachdem wie ihr zeit haben und in der
zeit kann eben das griechische die
flüssigkeit aufnehmen dann verändert
sich auch noch mal so ein bisschen die
konsistent ist und wir sehen uns später
wieder ihr lieben wir haben sie jetzt
ganz genau
21.45 und machen jetzt weiter das dürfte
bei mir jetzt ganz ich glaube drei oder
vier schon wenn man zwischenzeitlich
einkaufen als essen und ich habe gesagt
es könnte ja auch jetzt ein tag vorher
zubereiten tag lang wohnen das ist kein
problem ich habe es jetzt raus geholt
weil durch die butter wird das ziemlich
fest im kühlschrank daher könnte das wie
eine art mürbeteig erst mal so ein
bisschen weich kneten wenn ihr möchtet
aber ich habe es jetzt schon rausgeholt
und zeigt euch die dattel füllung ich
habe jetzt hier dazu passte und die gibt
es schon fertig zu kaufen das ist ein
hundertprozentiges naturprodukt und das
bieten wir auch im shop an das ist
einmal dieses hier sind 100 gramm drin
und das reicht dann einmal für den teig
zum modell aber wir müssen ihn jetzt
noch würzen weil so ist es ein bisschen
langweilig und er daher habe ich hier an
gewürzen zimt und fenchel und da gebe
ich auch noch ein bisschen sesam rahm
und dann kommt da noch einen schuss
orangenblüten und ein schuss rosenwasser
dazu
das war orangen dritten wasser und jetzt
kommt's rosenwasser und jetzt treten wir
das ganze diese klebrigen massen
attackierte ich mal gerne mit
handschuhen aber der liebe hamza hat
sich in der größe vertan
daher nehme ich jetzt die nackt und
sauberen sonst wüsstest du dass
verkneten weil das ja deine kurs ist
aber egal
[Musik]
und dieser befüllung ist auch schon
fertig ganz ganz wichtiger hinweis es
hat er haben sie bestimmt auch gerade
schon editiert das hier anis rein kommt
und kein ventil das war ein versprecher
von mir aber an dies passt wunderbar zur
deutsche passte und was schönes überlegt
dass wir eine art starter-set firma mode
machen die haupt füllung ist ja immer da
die füllung und deshalb habe ich mir
überlegt mache mir da so ein starter-kit
und falls ihr noch weitere füllung sehen
möchtet dann schreibt sie mir die
kommentare denn ich bin mir grad nicht
sicher denn das ist wirklich die
gefragteste füllung da bin ich mir gar
nicht sicher ob es vielleicht noch die
pisten oder die ware nicht verlängern
möchte
jetzt zeige ich euch wie das
funktioniert ich stecke mir jetzt hier
teig ab und da könnt ihr euch dann
aussuchen wie viel in dem ich nehme
jetzt hier die größte form und
dementsprechend brauche ich auch viel
teig und dann könnte ich mir das so ein
bisschen zurecht wie mit dem daumen rein
und mache mir platz für die füllung
jetzt wiederum stecke ich mir hier etwas
von meinem dackel oder doppelführung ab
und lege das hier rein könnt ihr
natürlich selber entscheiden wie viele
nimmt ich mag da gerne viel einfach in
die mitte gehen hoch und dann
verschließt ihr das ganz einfach
und jetzt kleiner trick am rande das
ganze ist jetzt verschlossen ich nehme
mir jetzt hier etwas mehl in meine form
und drückt das jetzt so mit der schönen
seite nach unten an wofür sie damit dass
gleich leichter rauskommt so ich habs
jetzt ein jahr lang nicht mehr gemacht
ich brauche noch mal ein bisschen übung
das ist jetzt hier ein bisschen viel
macht da so viel rein dass das halt so
gar nicht ab steht das am allerbesten
letztlich genau binde ich sollte mal
allererster nach einem jahr und jetzt
klopft ihr das hier so ein bisschen aus
und fertig und gleich mache ich den
nächsten
und dann habt ihr das ziemlich dann habt
ihr richtig schönes muster
[Musik]
euro
ein
hier habe ich jetzt auch noch welche
zubereitet mit der gleichen füllung aber
mit einem anderen mann vorm alter habe
ich jetzt im langen genommen wundert
euch nicht ihnen in unserem shop steht
jetzt zum beispiel hier pistazien
füllung und das hier ist die walnuss
füllung das schreiben wir zur
orientierung weil das so typisch ist
aber ihr könnt natürlich auch überall
jetzt die der verein machen sagte ich
finde es auch die landshuter süße wenn
man für drei verschiedene filme willst
du denn genau dann weiß man was drin
soll ich finde die land auch süß aber
die hier sind halt typisch und in jedem
fall sehen die alle toll aus und ich
werde das jetzt auf jeden fall schon
backen
richtig ist das jedoch alles schön
einzelnen takt je nachdem welche formen
verwendet weil die haben
unterschiedliche backzeit ich tippe
jetzt hier auf zehn bis elf minuten
wichtig ist dass die auch nicht zu
brauen werden sie dürfen ruhig hell sein
und nach dem backen zeige ich euch ein
live weiter vorgehen
die mol kekse sind jetzt ganz frisch aus
dem ofen und noch sehr sehr heiß ich
zeig euch mal von unten also unten
dürfen so ruhig etwas braun und oben
müssen sie unbedingt hell bleiben denn
nur dann sind so richtig schön mürbe und
was er jetzt macht direkt nach dem
backen also schön heißt einfach
puderzucker darauf geben puderzucker
ohne ende bediente zieht sich das in der
oberfläche noch mal zusammen und gibt
noch mal so ein bisschen süße und danach
lasse ich es aus köln
so und nachdenken sie auskühlen lassen
habt könnt ihr sie genießen zum tee zum
kaffee ganze leben möchte oder auch
verschenken das ist auch ganz ganz
typisch und ganz wichtig verpackt sie
luftdicht dann erhalten sie wie lange so
ungefähr zwei wochen also kann das nur
macht das nämlich auch immer ganz ganz
fleißig und dann tonnenweise und dann
handy überall verteilt ist auch mal
schön ist selber zu machen ich wünsche
euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen ich freue mich über eure
fotos mit dem hashtag des kitchen auf
instagram schaut auf jeden fall in die
video beschreibung der sind die genauen
mengenangaben die wichtigsten links zu
den produkten und den zutaten und dann
sagen wir ein schönes sommerfest wird
von jacko und hoya hoya wer zu faul ist
die selber zu backen der kann selber
kaufen wir haben die nämlich auch aus
der fabrik aber die schmecken perfekt
aber ob gehörs gemacht ist immer besser
gut jetzt wünsche ich euch noch einen
wunderschönen tag und ganz liebe grüße
von haben soll mir und bis zum nächsten
videos und wünsche ganz genau ein
schönes opferfest an alle
dies feiern
[Musik]